tout est possible aussi pour nos jeunes
qui sont avec peu depuis ce matin il dit
dans quelle galère je me suis mis mais
ça va bien se passer
johanna et nadir du lycée que je me
trompe pas un claude nicolas ledoux à
besançon vous êtes tous les deux
étudiants en bts c'est ça oui dans quel
métier banque a donc c'est vous qui
allez nous ne nous octroyer nos futurs
crédit nous avons entendu jérémy un ok
parfait alors très bien les métiers de
la banque mais là on va plutôt
s'intéresser à quoi précisément aux
inégalités hommes-femmes c'est ça c'est
ce que je disais tout à l'heure
oui pourquoi ça ben on a choisi ce sujet
là parce qu'on avait on est un groupe
des dix ouais parce qu'il faut dire
qu'il y en a en régie la qui vous
revient oui c'est ça ils vont se moquer
de vous après mais tout est normal
j'espère pas sur le but pour caen
surtout de moi je pense et on était une
majorité de femmes donc au sein de ce
groupe
donc on dit aux il y avait deux garçons
dont à dire et voilà dire courage ça va
le faire d'accord et ils nous ont
rejoints sur le fait qu' on prend pas
assez confus conscience qu'il existe
encore des inégalités hommes femmes et
qui persistent et puis on a choisi des
domaines précis pour parler de ce sujet
notamment dans le bain dans le travail
dans la vie quotidienne puis dans le
sport alors comment ça dans le travail
tient les inégalités au travail qui s'en
occupe c'est moi du travail pour que le
fait que le cercle des hommes est en
moyenne supérieur à celui des femmes de
34%
c'est que pour nous c'est un chiffre
choquant et c'est pourquoi moi et
johanna aujourd'hui 110 johanna et moi
parce que trois ans alors là ça va pas
être possible
et c'est pour ça qu'on représente les
femmes pour ba qui ont ce sentiment
d'injustice et qui sont dénigrés
ouais par exemple un couple d'amis de ma
mère qui travaille dans la même
entreprise et occupe le même poste ne
perçoit pas le même salaire et du coup
j'ai pu voir ça va causer des des
rivalités des disputes
ça pourrait même créer une certaine
jalousie bon et que les femmes peuvent
se sentir rabaisser quoi bien sûr
évidemment qui en a profité pour saluer
votre maman alors sans prénom c'est quoi
ces régimes à raz-el-ma hockey comme ça
si cette voie il sera fier de vous vous
avez parlé de travail je pense qu'il ya
aussi un petit peu de vie quotidienne
quelques pas renoncé c'est pour vous à
leur vie quotidienne
johanna bas on a pu voir que sur une
étude de l'insee les situe alors
national de la consommation inc seuil on
est d'accord
jérémy de mais vous viendrez les
acronymes mais c'est ok ben que les
femmes passent quand même plus de trois
heures en moyenne par jour aux tâches
quotidiennes comme les courses c'est
s'occuper des enfants faire le ménage et
faire à manger
oui c'est pas comptabilisé dans le reste
c'est pour ça et les hommes ans parce
que deux heures donc ils ont un peu plus
de temps que les femmes on va dire quand
ils rentrent chez eux
j'ai un exemple personnellement c'est
que à la maison jaune
enfin je m'occupais des tâches avec ma
maman et je faisais à manger à mon frère
alors qu'il aurait pu le faire aussi
[Rires]
on a salué l' la maman de nadir on va
être obligé de saluer votre maman jouait
ainsi que son prénom
s'il y en a comme ça il y aura pas de
jaloux là on fait vraiment la légalité
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de souci
ça veut dire peut-être aussi que les
femmes ont plus de temps libre c'est ça
non oui elles ont un petit peu plus de
temps libre pour faire du sport mais
enfin le sport
oui le sport j'ai j'ai cru comprendre
que c'était le sportif de l'équipe c'est
ça c'est ça alors au niveau du sport ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que c'était pas
pareil avant donc avant la femme pendant
les premiers jeux olympiques pas par
exemple où elles n'avaient pas accès à
ces compétitions
c'est le seul l'homme ne pouvait
participer alors aujourd'hui et
heureusement la situe la situe situation
de la femme a évolué dans la société ce
qui fait qu'elle peut participer aux
compétitions sportives
heureusement des super sportives savait
que on avait vendredi tient l'équipe de
france dans dispo en tout cas
l'entraîneur de l'équipe de france de
rang 10 sport il ya beaucoup de
sportives régionales qui sont un des
très hauts niveaux à votre place à lui
la championne du monde de parachutisme
championne olympique etc de plein de
choses j'ai fait il ya beaucoup de
champions qui passe et c'est souvent des
championnes aussi donc parenthèse
refermée parce que l'inter de champion
en bourgogne franche comté c'est pour ça
rien que la preuve vivante vous êtes des
futurs champions que je voulais ajouter
quelque chose à dire oui et donc même si
elles peuvent participer à ces
compétitions
elles sont toujours considérées comme
ayant moins de capacité est un mois
spectaculaires et moins intéressante
ce qui explique le fait que la part de
sport féminin dans les médias est très
faible
ça c'est pour nous un merci merci du ca
comme ça lui voilà voilà dix matin tout
de suite ça m'étonne humeur merci non il
ya quand même pas mal de choses qui sont
faites
au niveau sport et au féminin et tant
mieux
c'est un propos de sport ce soir un
petit pronostic pour l'équipe de france
non bon ok on verra bien peut-être un
but d'antoine griezmann ont parlé des
gens de la région là on a un champion un
champion en conclusion et pour être un
tout petit peu sérieux là sur les
inégalités hommes femmes
nadir et johan bien on a pu voir quand
même que ce sujet a été abordé puisqu'il
ya eu quand même des améliorations des
évolutions notamment pour les femmes au
niveau du travail
maintenant elles ont un compte bancaire
et leur salaire est versé sur leur
compte alors qu'auparavant non c'était
ceux versés sur le compte bancaire et du
mari c'est des futurs banquiers qui en
parlent et et puis elles ont quand même
eu du temps libre parce que des hommes
se sont mis un peu aux tâches de
quotidienne donc elles sont pu se mettre
au sport par exemple mais c'est quand
même restreint en tout cas c'était votre
avis nous le respecte voilà il est tout
ça grâce aux clés mis parce que le clemi
permet aux élèves d'apprendre à lire à
décrypter l'information à l'image choses
que vous savez faire j'imagine à
aiguiser votre esprit critique à se
forger une opinion et ses échanges entre
jeunes et médias bon n'en partagent
quelques-uns comme ça de temps en temps
dans la matinale et c'est toujours un
plaisir et on dirait que merci à tous
les deux vous restez jusqu'au bout ça va
ça se passe bien